he's one of our favorite guests we've
enjoyed him through the years bill
Livingston Cleveland Plain Dealer
columnist who decided to retire and bill
let me start with the obvious question
if LeBron had stayed in Cleveland would
you still be writing for the Cleveland
Plain Dealer no this has been in plans
I'm 70 I wanted to max out my government
benefits the hours had gotten awfully
long especially at Ohio State games
which I love but you know one hundred
nine thousand people for the big games
you had to get there three hours earlier
you got there 15 minutes earlier with
their shirttail flapping because of the
crowds and for our games and you know if
it was a 3:30 game usually our noon game
he had to drive back two hours and 15
minutes to Cleveland just you know in
the Finals games being so late but I am
going to write one a week or so oh good
and yeah and I'll be I'll be covering
all of the last breath here and they've
told me I can do any Ohio State home
game I want to do although only Michigan
looks very good this year
so semi-retirement I'd say did you see
this coming with LeBron was there any
chance Cleveland could have retained him
only a scant chance I think had they had
their pattern in the past being insanely
lucky in the in the lottery in which
they got LeBron Kyrie Irving and Andrew
Wiggins who was the ammunition to get
Kevin Love if they had gotten a 1 or 2
pick and it had been really an eye
catching you know acquisition I think
that was the only way because this team
wasn't going to go gonna be able to beat
the Warriors and I don't know who is
going to right now anywhere but I
thought he was going to leave and as
I've told as I've said to everybody and
as I said in print I I think most people
in Cleveland had completely different
views than last time he's a different
guy now gratitude and appreciation and
you know
best wishes that's that's the way I feel
about it what did you make of a tyronn
lue saying that he was going to talk to
Luke Walton about how to coach LeBron
James
well Chiron and Chiron had better luck
than then David Blatt certainly but
LeBron has always been a difficult
player to coach as you know for obvious
reasons he so makes such a difference on
the floor he has such a say in what goes
on in the organization I think things
will be fine in LA because there was
just such a gulf between LeBron and Dan
Gilbert I mean LeBron really does not
like tan Gilbert on lots of grounds not
not only the letter that he sent out you
know culturally politically just about
every way you even think of except
economically they're they're different
people yeah I wasn't sure how big a role
that was going to play but you know that
the LeBron going to Los Angeles and what
that means for this team if you were
gonna say to Laker fans be prepared for
this what would this be with LeBron and
almost an almost inevitable period of
disenchantment where he mopes around and
there's a prima donna for a few games
and then gearing back up for the
playoffs and you know fasten your seat
belts because in the playoffs he will do
things that you have seldom seen it's
it's like when I covered dr. J also you
every night although with LeBron I think
it says now at this stage of his career
in the biggest games you may see
something that you know like Olga Korbut
at the Olympics that no one had ever
seen before
you know it really is it was just a joy
watching him play the last four years
and and I had 11 years with him and fire
with Doc so I don't have any complaints
what about the Cavaliers post LeBron
well in the past they fell off the cliff
post LeBron they have little experience
in trying to develop players and really
unless you just get a mega talent like
LeBron or Kyrie in the draft that's
really not the way teams are built for
championships anymore it's free agent
acquisitions and and trades I will see
how it goes you know it will probably be
some I don't know whether it'll be the
complete desert it was before but it's
certainly not going to be a I know
Eastern Conference championship he's
Bill Livingston Cleveland Plain Dealer
columnist joining a Stan Patrick show do
you believe that Dan Gilbert wanted his
team back that he's okay with LeBron
leaving but not that he had a say in it
but do you believe the net that he
really he's glad to have this team now
back well I don't know I mean he was one
of them
besides the personal conflicts you know
he let David Griffin walk who was a
LeBron favorite and who had done a great
job as a general manager and you know I
I don't know how much of it was
Gilbert's fault he's putting the best
face on it and it was nice that he sent
out a letter that had a little class -
at this time I'm like the first time and
you know I was told I was on LeBron -
but you know not like he was nobody was
a former player like he was you know I
personally am not very fond of man
Gilbert but you know I tried to just not
discuss him or if I did to be fair about
it I think he's he's beloved here in
Cleveland because he spends the money
and that's always been the problem with
owners here but what problem did you
have in something I said on Tony
Kornheiser show that was I believe to be
true but was basically just informed
speculation that he resented and I had
to apologize and it was probably correct
that I did although I still think I was
correct one of those Trump apologies I'm
sorry if I offended you if I said you
could have no-holds-barred interview
with LeBron or Dan Gilbert I'm supposed
to choose yeah oh well I like LeBron I'd
take LeBron yeah but don't you think
you'd get more interesting things out of
Dan Gilbert maybe I wanted to ask him
about when he spoke to the to the
Buckeyes which was surprising because it
was you know he's a Michigan State guy
and a very loyal alumnus and a
contributor to them
and I wanted to talk to him before the
Michigan game and he wouldn't do it and
you know I I don't know what he wanted
to he her bin' had asked him to come in
as he does you know business leaders to
come in and talk about life in the
business world to his players as they're
nearing graduation and he wouldn't do it
and he didn't want to do it ever and I
you know I don't know what he said it
was probably a bunch of stuff about
mortgage rates or something but it would
have been interesting to me but he
didn't want to go there and I don't
really want to go there with him yeah
it's fascinating I'm pretty much done
with Dan Gilbert and people Art Modell
and people like that had real problems
with but you know the fact that he won a
title there helps him whereas Modell you
know what happens you're sure he and
he's busted the salary cap and going way
into the luxury tax that's one yeah
that's why the average fan you know
likes him there's no question about that
and and it is to be saluted but you know
there are these others there are these
other issues with him know he spent the
money and you know the Dolans don't have
it and there's a hard salary cap in the
NFL so there you have it you need a
basketball owner who can spend money you
know and he had he wants a casino nobody
but Trump ever lost money on casinos
that I know um bill enjoy your semi
retirement and we appreciate the time
all right thank you all right bill
Livingston Cleveland Plain Dealer
columnist retiring you know he'd seen it
all with the Cleveland Browns used to be
in Philadelphia so we covered the 76ers
with dr. J and then LeBron James for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
channel 239 on Direct TV or download the
Dan Patrick show app
[Music]